you can might meet your microphone yeah
i'm okay now thank you
would you mind muting your microphones
i'll pick a pardon yep okay thank you
okay everybody welcome back are we live
streaming now sonia
my screen's saying we are
yeah just just uh just a moment chairman
yeah we're live
now okay okay
uh welcome back to um watch district
council
uh part two the decision section of this
uh application for
uh premises license um
i apologize for the delay in to all
members all uh participants and that's
coming back to you obviously this is a
serious matter for us to consider we've
had to take our time and do it properly
so
please forgive us for that turning first
to the application for a premises
license the committee has considered all
of the written evidence and
representations made
at the hearing the committee has also
considered the conditions submitted by
the police
and environmental health in order to
promote the licensing objectives
the committee has listened carefully to
concerns raised by interested parties
relating to the potential for
compromising the licensing objectives
relating to the prevention of public
nuisance motion of public safety
and prevention of crime disorder by
virtue of residents living in close
proximity to the premises i.e above
adjacent to an opposite the premises
however
the committee was sensitive the fact
that no representations were made at the
hearing by essex police
and environmental health furthermore the
police and environmental health have
agreed conditions with the applicant
they consider will serve
to promote these licensing objectives
the committee has resolved to grant the
premises license
subject to standard conditions and the
conditions agreed by the police
environmental health
and the applicant in addition
subject to the following additional
conditions
no licensable activity is to take place
at the premises whatsoever until
such time as appropriate soundproofing
has been installed
independently and agreed with
environmental health
the second additional condition is that
no license
sorry licensable activities will be
restricted we're restricting the hours
those hours will now be 11 am until 2100
hours
sunday to thursday and 10 a.m
until 2200 hours on friday saturday
the committee has reduced the hours for
licensable activity to address the
significant
and profound concern about residents
with children living in very close
proximity
above adjacent to and opposite the
premises which is
in addition not in a town centre
location
furthermore the committee notes that the
smoking area at the rear of the premises
will be considered as part of the change
of use
planning application that is still yet
to be determined
the committee also notes that the
premises can apply for up to 12
temporary event notices per annum for
special events
turning now to the application for a
pavement light permission license
the committee has considered all the
written evidence and verbal evidence
presented to the hearing
and whilst noting the applicant's
willingness to comply with any
restrictions a committee might feel
appropriate to impose
nevertheless considers that the license
should be refused
the committee in coming to this decision
has done so
in response to concerns relating to
public safety that had been raised by
responsible authorities notably the
police
and the environmental health the
committee noted in particular
the suggestion
in appendix e to the report page 5.30
that the business
could reapply for a pavement permission
license after it has operated as a bar
for at least six months and demonstrated
that it could do so
without compromising public safety or
causing public nuisance
the committee would like to remind all
those present that the applicant
must adhere to all the conditions
applied to this premises
license and if there are any problems in
the future as a result of the grant of
this license
a review of the license can be requested
at any time
this now concludes the hearing and i
thank you all for attending
you